انفجار لغم في دير الزور السوريه يخلف
قتلى وجرحى والمرصد يتحدث عن استهداف
المستشفى الايراني
الجيش الاسرائيلي يطلق صافرات الانذار عقب
اطلاق صاروخ من غزه باتجاه مستوطنات
قائد
يطلع قاده غربيين على سير المعارك
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا بمدينه كوفيد البريطانيه ينضم
الينا مدير المنصه السوري لحقوق الانسان
رامي عبد الرحمن اهلا بك سيدي رامي معنا
في هذه النشره والانبا حتى الان تبدو
متضاربه ما طبيعه هذه الهجمات التي طالت
منطقه دير الزور وهل هي نتائج لغم كما
يقول النظام السوري ام طائره مسيره كما
تقول بعض المصادر نعم صباح الخير
يسبب هذا الانفجار الضخم في تلك المنطقه
الانفجار كان بالتزامن مع التحليق طائره
مسيره عند ضفاف الفرات الانفجار وقع في
مستودع للايرانيين تحديدا المستودع
للصواريخ قصيره المدى وكان هناك انفجار
وتهدم مباني اي نغم يتسبب بتهدم مباني
وتدمير بشكل تلك بشكل كبير في تلك المنطقه
حتى اللحظه هناك اربعه قتلى مؤكدين واكثر
في هذا الانفجار او يشير من طائره مسيره
استهدفت هذه المنطقه بالتزامن مع وصول
شاحنه كبيره محمله
بانابيب تستخدم لاجل تصنيع صواريخ قصيره
المدى في تلك البقعه من التراب السوري
المسيطر عليها من قبل الايرانيين ويوجد
فيها مشفى ايراني في تلك المنطقه ايضا
يوجد مصنع لتصنيع بين مناطق المدنيه حقيقه
الامر لتصنيع او تجهيز او تجميع الصواريخ
صواريخ قصيره المدى الايرانيه التابعه
للميليشيات في هذه البقعه من الجغرافيا
السوريه ويوجد في تلك المنطقه مساكن لحجاج
او ما يعرف بقاده من حزب الله والحرس
الثوري الايراني يقتلون في تلك المنطقه لا
لهم ولا غير لغه يتسبب بهذا الانفجار
الهائل ويتسبب بتساقط اجزاء من مباني
وتدبير التي شاهدناه بالصوت والصوره
وارسلنا شريط مصور وصور حجم هذا الانفجار
الضخم في اتجاه هذه الصور المتابعها ايضا
معك على شاشه قناه العربيه سيد رامي لكن
هذه المنطقه كما تفضلت هي تابع النظام
السوري وايضا بها ميليشيات متحالفه معها
ما طبيعه نعم تفضل
عن النظام السوري ولكن تتواجد فيها
ميليشيات حزب الله وميليشيات ايرانيه
ويوجد فيها المشفى الايراني او ما يعرف
بمشفى البوليرا في تلك المنطقه ومصطفى
ايرانيه وايضا تبين ان يوجد ايضا فيها
المصنع لتجميع الصواريخ قصيره المدى
الايرانيه الموجوده المسيطره على تلك
المنطقه الانفجارات كانت بالتزام او
الانفجار حقيقه
بالتزامن مع التحليق طائره مسيره عند ضفاف
الفرات هل بالطائره الامريكيه الطائره
اسرائيليه لا نعلم ولكن الاستهداف هو حصرا
للايرانيين في هذه البقعه من الجغرافيه
السوريه وليس لغم مثلما الدعم النظام الذي
نشر الخبر بعد ساعات من حدوثه
وهذا المصنع وهذه المنشات جميعها في مناطق
سكنيه ليس كذلك عن وسط المنطقه السكنيه
التي يتواجد فيها مدنيون نعم نعم يعني
اولا منطقه سكنيه يوجد فيها مدنيين
والشاحنات التي قالوا بانها تحمل واد
غذائيه تبين بانها لا تحمل مواد غذائيه
تحمل يعني صوره للشاحنه وهي تحمل انابيب
مختصه بالصواريخ الصواريخ المدى المصنعه
من قبل الايرانيين اي ان هذا يؤكد ما
قلناه سابقا بان كثير من الشحنات التي
تدخل من العراق ليست شاحنات مواد غذائيه
او برادات المواد الغذائيه بل هي برادات
شاحنات سلاح تحمل السلاح الايرانيين تصل
بدايه للبكمال ومن ثم للميادين بعد ذلك
يجري نقله تباعا باتجاه مدينه دير الزور
ولكن ان تبني مصنع لتصنيع الذخيره في
منطقه مدنيه فهذا يدل بان ايران لا تهتم
بالبدنيين ولا تابع للمدنيين وتقوم باخذ
المدنيين دروع بشريه لحمايه داخل الاراضي
السوريه كيف تعاطت هذه الميليشيات بشكل
امني مع هذه الهجمات خاصه وانها تاتي ايضا
بعد هجمات بعد اقم اروع 24 اقل من هجمات
مماثله على مطار حلب كيف هو المشهد الان
من حيث اتخاذ الاجراءات الامنيه
كان هناك اعاده في ريف الميادين اين حلب
واين الميادين وكان هناك وجود لوصول التي
باتت كبيره جدا داخل التراب السوري الى
المنطقه الواقعه مع شرط الميادين باتجاه
البوكمال اي ان هناك تحركات مستمره لهذه
الميليشيات مع كل ضربه اسرائيليه او كل
تحرك امريكي وهنا قلنا امس بان القضيه لم
تعد تتعلق فقط في اسرائيل بل باتت تتعلق
بامريكا التي تستهدف سرا القوات الايرانيه
الموجوده داخل الاراضي السوريه شكرا لك
بمدينه كوفنت البريطانيه كنت معنا مدير
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد
الرحمن تحياتي
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه مشاهدينا لا يزال
التوتر امني سيد الموقف مع اطلاق صافرات
الانذار هذا الصباح ردا على اطلاق صاروخ
من غزه الجيش الاسرائيلي كان قتل سته
فلسطينيين في جنين ما يرفع العدد الى
اربعه وسبعين قتيلا منذ بدايه العام في
التفاصيل ايضا اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي رصد
عمليه اطلاق صاروخ من قطاع غزه صوب
مستوطنه الغلاف ما ادى الى تفعيل صافره
الانذار بها من جهتها قالت مصادر محليه في
قطاع غزه ان الفصائل الفلسطينيه اطلقت
صاروخين من نوع 107 باتجاه موقع عسكري
اسرائيلي في مستوطنه في مستوطنات غلاف غزه
الجيش الاسرائيلي كان رفع حاله التاهب
القصوى بعد عمليه عسكريه ادت الى مقتل سته
فلسطينيين بينهم منفذ عمليه حواره التي
تسببت في مقتل مستوطنين
هذا اتهمت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه اسرائيل بشن
حرب مفتوحه على الفلسطينيين بعد اقتحام
لمخيم جنين اسفر عن مقتل سته فلسطينيين
بينما قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه استهدف
منفذ عمليه حوار
الثانيه ظهرا تتوغل قوات خاصه اسرائيليه
في شاحنه تجاريه وقوات كبيره من الجيش
الاسرائيلي والطيران الحربي يحلق فرقها
مخيم جنين يحاصرون هذا المنزل وتبدا
المعركه مع من تحصنوا بداخله
كان الاتفاق النار نوعين نوع يعني عليه
كاتمه هذا القوات الخاصه ونعادي ثمره
المعركه طبعا ضرب على بيتنا قضيه ان يرجع
الاول ثم بدا اطلاق الصواريخ على الكتف
على هذا المنزل علمنا من وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ان المستهدف منزل جارنا فجلسنا
هنا اطلقت 16 قذيفه كتف
هذا الدمار قد يدلل على ان الوضع الميداني
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه معزول تماما عن
الوضع السياسي وسط ضغوط امريكيه واوروبيه
لتهدئه الاوضاع على الارض ترافقها تصريحات
رسميه اسرائيليه بالتزامها بالتهدئه من
مخيم جنين خالد القاسم العربيه
في ملف الحرب الاوكراني اعلن مؤسس شركه
يوفنر الروسيه عن سيطره القوات الروسيه
على كامل القسم الشرقي لمدينه بخماد ونقل
المكتب الاعلامي لشركه عن قول حين قوه
العسكريه الخاصه سيطرت على كامل القسم
الشرقي لمدينه وان كل ما يقع شرق نهر تحت
سيطرتها
ومن جانبه التقى القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه
مسؤولين عسكريين كبارا يمثلون الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا
لم يتم ذكرها طلبني كشف في اللقاء الذي
جرى امس الثلاثاء عن سير المعارك في شرق
اوكرانيا خاصه معارك بخمد كما جرى بحث
حاجه الجيش الاوكراني على جبهات القتال
بما فيها الاسلحه والذخيره
هيئه الاركان في الجيش الاوكراني اعلنت في
هذا السياق التصدي باكثر من 100 هجوم في
باخم ومارينكا وبقيه محاوله
ان الهجمات الروسيه تضمنت 24 غاره جويه
و60 قصفا صاروخيا بمنصات اطلاق صواريخ
متعدده وطائرات مسيره ايرانيه الصنع
واضافت هيئه اركان الاوكرانيه ان الطيران
الاوكراني استهدف خمسه تجمعات للقوات
الروسيه وثلاثه مستودعات للوقود بسبع
غارات جويه
حادثه تفجير خط انابيب الغاز نورد ستريم
للغاز الرابط بين روسيا واوروبا تعود الى
الواجهه مع ظهور معطيات جديده تتهم فريقا
اوكرانيا بتنفيذ الهجوم شهر سبتمبر العام
الماضي
طالب بتحقيق شفاف في الحادثه التي احدثت
لغطا كبيرا في هذا السياق مشاهدينا دعه
المتحدثه باسم الخارجي الروسيه ماريا في
مواد في مواد التحقيق الصحفي الذي انجزه
الصحفي الامريكي سيمور هيرج بشان تفجير خط
انابيب
واكدت زخرفه على ان الغرب لا يريد البحث
عن الحقيقه ولا يريدون اجراء تحقيق قانوني
في الحادثه وورد في تقرير صحفي امريكي ان
عسكريين امريكيين اوسقوا عبوات ناسفه بخط
انا بالنورسريم او السيل الشمالي اثناء
المناورات العسكريه للنيتو صيف العام
الماضي وبعد ثلاثه اشهر فجرها النرويجيون
في مياههم
هذا وكشف الصحيفه ديسايت الالمانيه في
تحقيق خاص ان محققين دوليين عثروا على
القارب الذي استخدم لتفريخ انابيب اسفل
بحر البلطيق وكان قد استاجره شخصان
اوكرانيا من شركه مقرها بولندا ولكن لم
يعطي المحققون بعد على الجهه التي امرت
بتنفيذ عمليه التفجير وبحسب التحقيقات وقد
نفد العمليه فريق كوماندوس اوكراني مؤلف
من سته اشخاص خمسه رجال وسيده نقلوا
المتفجرات على القارب وابحر من ميناء
روستوك الالماني في السادس من سبتمبر
الماضي
وقال مندوب روسيا لدى الامم المتحده ان
التقرير الذي يتحدث عن طوارئ اوكرانيا
بتفجيرستريم يبرر طلب موسكو اجراء تحقيق
مستقل بهذا الشان من جانبها قالت الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ان لا علاقه لكياف بتفجير خط
نورتي ستريم بدورها اكدت الحكومه
الالمانيه ان التحقيق المشترك مع دنمارك
والسويد بشان تفجير مستمر ولم يصل لنتيجه
بعد وذلك بعد ان تحدث الصحيفه عن تقييم
للاستخبارات الامريكيه اشار الى ان مجموعه
اوكرانيه نفذت الهجوم على خطوط العام
الماضي كما اشار التقرير الى انه لم يثبت
بعد ما اذا كان الرئيس الاوكراني على علم
بالهجوم الذي قد يكون نفذ من مجموعه
اوكرانيه
مستمره مشاهدينا او فيها بعد الفاصل
اوروبا تطالب ايران باجابات عن السبب وجود
اثري يورانيوم عالي التخصيب في احدى
المنشات النوويه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد نستان من الملف
النووي الايراني حيث اكد متحدث في مجلس
محافظ الاتحاد الاوروبي ان الاتحاد مازال
ملتزما بالاتفاق النووي مع ايران واعرب
المتحدث الاوروبي عن قلقه الشديد من
العثور على اثار اليورانيوم مخصب بنسبه
تقارب
84% وقال ان هذا الامر تطورا خطير وغير
مسبوق ودع المتحدث ايران للتعاون بشكل
كامل وجفاف مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الداريه بشان العثور على اثار يورانيوم
على التخصيب في احدى المنشات النوويه
هذا وداع مندوب روسيا لدى المنظمات
الدوليه في فيينا ميخائيل جميع المشاركين
في المحادثات النوويه الايرانيه دعاهم
للعوده الى العاصمه النمساويه من اجل
احياء الاتفاق النووي وقال اوليانوب في
البيان الروسي بشان الملف الايراني امام
مجلس محافظ الوكاله الدوليه انه يمكن
تبديد مخاوفهم العديد بسهوله مشترطا عوده
المشاركين في المحادثات الى فيينا من اجل
وضع اللمسات الاخيره في غضون ايام قليله
على مسوده قرار بشان استعاده العمل
بالاتفاق النووي
يحدث هذا في وقت طالب كبير الجمهوريين في
لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي طالب الولايات المتحده بالتركيز
على خطه بديله فيما يتعلق بملف نووي
الايراني وقال ريتش عبر تويتر انما وصفها
بالمغامره النوويه الايرانيه تتطلب توبيخا
صريحا من مجلس محافظ الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه
وفي قضيه تسميم فتيات ايران وفي حديث
للعربي شددت المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض
كارين على انه يجب ان لا تمر انتهاك بحقوق
الانسان التي ترتكبها طهران ضد متظاهرين
دون محاسبه
في افغانستان مستمر مروه حاله منهن سيده
افغانيه
الى مكان ما في افغانستان فرت مروه
واولادها مكان غير معلوم حتى لوالدتها
مروه ام لثمانيه اطفال ست فتيات وطفلين
نالت مطلبها بالطلاق من زوجها قبل استيلاء
طالبان على السلطه بسته اشهر لكنها اليوم
لان طالبان الحاكمه الغى الطلاقها من
زوجها
كان دائما يختلق الاسباب لضربي ومنها انه
يريد اطفالا ذكورا بعدد اكبر
هنا في هذا البلد حيث يتنامى القهر والخوف
لدى فئه هي الاكثر استضعافا نساء
افغانستان
تسعون من كل عشر نساء يقعن ضحايا العنف
الجسدي والجنسي من جانب شريكهن بحسب بعثه
الامم المتحده في البلاد
مروه اختارت الغربه في بلدها لا تعرف احدا
وتخشى اعلام حتى والدتها بمكانها خوفا من
ان تعثر عليها السلطات اختارت خياطه
الملابس مهنه تعتاش منها وربما من سخريه
القدر ان المحامي التي لجات اليها مروه
اسمها ظريفه وهو اسم وهمي اختارته خوفا من
طالبان التي منعتها عن ممارسه عملها تحاول
مروى الاختفاء قد تنجو وربما لا لكن
محاميتها المفترضه تقول ان حاله مروى ليست
الوحيده فضريفه تلقت على الاقل خمسه
اتصالات في الاشهر الماضيه من نساء مطلقات
يطلبن مساعدتها حنان المصري العربيه
وبقي مشاهدينا ان نذكر باب الرز العناوين
انفجار لغم ان في دير الزهره السوريه يخلف
قتلى وجرحى والمرصد يتحدث عن استهداف
المستشفى الايراني
الجيش الاسرائيلي يطلق صافرات الانذار عقب
اطلاق صاروخ من غزه باتجاه مستوطنات
حدوديه
على الجهه الشرقيه
على سير المعارك
وا بعافيه
[موسيقى]
لكم ان تتخيلوا ان جميع طرقات هذه القريه
بهذا الشكل الدمار هائل جدا هذه كانت
مدينه حرب في شوارع بوتا تتفقدها تتفقد
الطرقات وتجد صدفه جثه في احدى الطرقات
هذا ما حدث معنا للثوب
سنتقدم معكم بحذر شديد لانه ربما تكون
هنالك ذخيره او قنابل هنالك قنابل يدويه
هنالك ذخيره واليات عسكريه مدمره في كل
مكان اينما نظرت تجد اليات عسكريه لقناتي
العربيه والحدث عمار الهندي من جانبي
بمقبره جماعيه
كل قد لا يكون حقيقه يجب التسليم بها
فمهما بلغت اهميه الخبر
تاكيده او نفيه
يعتمد فقط على المصدر كواليس وسائل
الاعلام العربيه والعالميه في التفاعل مع
الاخبار على كل المنصات سنحاول ربط خيوط
القصه ونطارد الخبر حتى المصدر من المصدر
الجمعه السابعه والنصف على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
ازرق هادئ
بديع الجمال
لفه السكون والسحر والخيال
افزعته خطوات ثقيله
تسعى للفناء
بدات العمليه في العشرين من مارس عام 2003
[موسيقى]
دموع ثقلاء
كلها راحت والان توبرياء
لكن ما الذي يحصل الان الان الان
مزقته الحناجر الفرحه
او فشعه بالتاريخ
من هذه المناطق الساخنه الهبته مدافع
اصوات المدعيه الان
وطائرات بدات العمليات العسكريه في تمام
الساعه الثانيه صباحا
وكروت وتقلبات
[موسيقى]
في الرابع عشر من فبراير عام 2005 وبينما
اشتدت
واستحكمت صراعات
واطبقت في البر والبحر يا زمان والابرياء
يموتون في نفس المكان في كل بقعه مرتهبه
في قلبي كل حدث
[موسيقى]
كنا هناك